[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
abend ihnen allen schönen dass sie dabei
sind wie auch norbert lehmann für den
sport journal blog von mir der krieg
hinterlässt auch in deutschland spuren
erste waren stufe die bundesregierung
bereitet sich auf engpässe bei der
gasversorgung vor
kein nachlassen der kämpfe trotz
positiver signale nach den verhandlungen
in istanbul greifen die russen in der
ukraine und vermindert an
und rekordanstieg bei den
verbraucherpreisen
7,3 prozent so hoch war die inflation 40
jahren nicht
noch ist die gasversorgung in
deutschland sicher das sagt der
wirtschaftsminister aber er will das
land für den fall wappnen dass russland
seine lieferungen einstellen deshalb
aktivierte robert habeck heute die früh
waren stufe des notfallplans damit tritt
ein krisenteam aus behörden und
energieversorgern zusammen bei stufe 2
der alarmstufe sollen zusätzliche
beschaffungsmöglichkeiten ausgelotet
werden kommt es zu massiven
lieferausfällen gilt stufe 3 die notfall
stufe dann entscheidet die
bundesnetzagentur wer wie viel gas
bekommt besonders geschützt sind private
haushalte aber auch krankenhäuser
feuerwehr und polizei weniger
hier in h sechs ministerien laufen nun
täglich alle informationen über die
gasversorgung hierzulande
zusammengesammelt von bundesnetzagentur
und energieversorgern dieser krisenstab
beobachte den gasmarkt er greift aber
nicht ein der wirtschaftsminister in die
früh warnstufe einen formalen schritt er
versucht gleichzeitig zu beruhigen dass
die versorgungssicherheit gewährleistet
ist dass alle verträge eingehalten
werden und dass das gas und das öl nach
deutschland kommt im moment wie bestellt
ist also eine prävention oder vorsorge
entscheidung die ich heute getroffen
habe die ausrufung der früh warnstufe
finden stadtwerke und energieversorger
sinnvoll solche fahrpläne würden
sicherheit schaffen
die endet im moment hinsichtlich der
versorgungssicherheit gar nichts nur
dass der bund jetzt aufgefordert sich
intensiver mit dem thema zu beschäftigen
und vor allen dingen pläne zu entwickeln
wenn wir in die stufe 2 gehen dass auch
versorgungs einschränkungen durchgeführt
werden können versorgungs
einschränkungen würden zuerst die
industrie treffen ob der fall eintritt
oder nicht kann derzeit niemand sagen
ich denke wir sollten in kürzester zeit
drei dinge tun das erste ist aus
verschiedenen ländern gas beziehen das
zweite ist dass wir die speicher füllen
gerade über den sommer dass wir über den
winter dann sehr gut vorbereitet sind
das dritte ist ein energiesparprogramm
starten energie sparen das ist auch
robert habeck zweite botschaft an alle
heute
sind in einer situation wo ich klar
sagen muss dass jede eingesparte stunde
kilowattstunde energie hilft derselbe
rat kommt auch von den wirtschaftsweisen
auch weil sie mit dauerhaft höheren
energiepreisen rechnen
die menschen müssen jetzt weniger
verbrauchen wir sollen
fahrgemeinschaften bilden die sonnen
langsamer fahren sie sollen den
öffentlichen nahverkehr verwenden so
sieht das denn können 40 prozent
deutscher gasimporte kommen nur aus
russland die bundesregierung sagt die
könne man nicht von heute auf morgen
ersetzen
weitere tipps zum energiesparen finden
sie in unserer zdf heute app dort zeigen
wir zum beispiel wie viel weniger
energie sie verbrauchen wenn sie die
raumtemperatur um ein grad senken
nämlich sechs prozent eines von vielen
beispielen
offen ist ob wie und wann russland ernst
macht mit seiner forderung gas nur noch
für gut zu verkaufen heute telefonierte
bundeskanzler scholz mit präsident putin
dabei habe man sich nach kreml angaben
darauf verständigt dass jetzt erst mal
experten der jeweiligen länder das ganze
beraten sollen über russisches gas und
die sanktions gebeutelte wirtschaft
berichtet aus moskau christian senn
wladimir putin weiß ganz genau dass sein
gas auch ein vortrefflicher
energieträger dafür ist europa politisch
unter druck zu setzen heute heißt es aus
moskau das gas müsse nicht sofort in
rubel bezahlt werden klang die tage noch
anders
zahlungen und lieferungen sind ein
zeitraubender prozess es ist nicht so
dass das was morgen geliefert wird bis
zum abend bezahlt werden muss die
westlichen sanktionen treffen auch die
russische luftfahrtamt ohne flugverkehr
stark eingeschränkt und russland will
geleaste maschinen aus europa und den
usa nicht zurückgeben es geht um rund
500 maschinen im wert von rund zehn
milliarden dollar russland kann diese
flugzeuge natürlich behalten unterbruch
des kapstadter abkommens das macht es
ganz schwierig aber mit diesen
flugzeugen können sie erstens natürlich
jetzt nur noch innerhalb von russland
fliegen denn in jedem anderen land das
im café dass der kap-staat konvention
angehört wird dieses flugzeug sofort an
die kette gelegt und zweitens wird es
natürlich später schwierig sein
überhaupt noch nie singen flugzeuge zu
bekommen wer in russland öffentlich
probleme anspricht bekommt selbst welche
ein manager der russischen
luftfahrtbehörde wurde gefeuert nachdem
er gesagt hatte man werde wegen der
sanktionen schwierigkeiten bekommen die
maschinen zu warten russland wird
versuchen sich die ersatzteile
anderweitig zu besorgen
ich denke dass einige maschinen
tatsächlich für ersatzteile
ausgeschlachtet werden denn es gibt
viele flugzeuge mehrere hunde
im staatsfernsehen ging es heute auch
noch mal um die gespräche gestern
zwischen der ukraine und russland in
istanbul russland zeigt sich
optimistisch dass die eigenen
forderungen erfüllt werden
entscheidend ist ja was der kreml zu den
vorschlägen aus den gestrigen
verhandlungen sagt dieser welt männer in
moskau wie reagiert die regierung putin
im moment noch verhalten barbara hahlweg
die gespräche in istanbul werden hier
nicht unbedingt als durchbruch
bezeichnet allerdings sieht dimitri
peskow der kreml sprecher durchaus
positive zeichen darin dass die
ukrainische seite der delegation ganz
konkrete vorschläge erarbeitet habe und
diese wolle man jetzt vladimir putin
weiterleiten wladimir putin selbst hat
sich heute nicht zu diesen verhandlungen
geäußert und in den russischen
staatsmedien werden die gespräche in
istanbul
erfolgreich bezeichnet und es wird auch
nicht mehr grundsätzlich ausgeschlossen
dass es zu einem persönlichen treffen
zwischen seelands die und putin kommen
kann diesem wunsch von salewski nach
einem persönlichen treffen wurde ja bis
vor zwei tagen zumindest noch ganz kühl
hier aus moskau eine abfuhr erteilt
dankeschön nach moskau dieser welt
termine wahr dass
und soeben erreicht uns noch diese
meldung aus dem zdf hauptstadtstudio
russlands präsident putin soll in dem
telefonat mit kanzler scholz angeboten
haben europäische partner könnten gas
weiterhin in euro über die gazprombank
bezahlen scholz will diesen vorschlag
zunächst prüfen lassen bislang gilt laut
verträgen energielieferungen werden in
euro oder dollar bezahlt
der ukrainische präsident lenski bleibt
skeptisch was die verhandlungen mit
russland angeht die ukraine seien kein
naives volk sagte er in seiner
nächtlichen videoansprache
ausgeführt berichtet die stadt sei trotz
des angekündigten abzug der russen
weiter unter schweren beschuss schlimmes
zeigt sich auch dort wo ukrainische
soldaten gelände zurückerobern thomas
garcia online aus berichten
ihr team vor den toren der hauptstadt
überreste von zivilisation viele flohen
viele die blieben überlebten die
angriffe nicht 200 tote zählt die
kleinstadt nun ist ihr ping befriedet
russische truppen abgezogen sie
hinterlassen zerstörung und leid
überlebende berichten von
vergewaltigungen von brutalität von
kriegsverbrechen
sie haben einfach männer auf der straße
erschossen
russische soldaten haben zivilisten
gezwungen sich auszuziehen männer wie
frauen sie haben sie in eine reihe
gestellt geschlagen und gedemütigt
was in ihr team geschah ermittler sollen
das nun überprüfen fest steht laut
beobachtern zwar minimiert russland
truppen nach kiew doch luftangriffe
gehen weiter auch in cerny hilfe dort
trafen raketen diesen markt entgegen der
russischen ankündigung gestern sagt der
gouverneur
der feind hat diese reduzierung
militärische aktivitäten dadurch
demonstriert dass er unsere region aus
der luft angegriffen und die ganze nacht
cerny hilf getroffen hat
auch im krankenhaus zeigt sich die
infrastruktur der stadt ist weitgehend
zerstört es fehlt an medikamenten an
personal an allem
wir arbeiten hier ohne licht sagt der
chef der chirurgie ohne wasserversorgung
ohne heizung
manchmal fügt eine krankenschwester
hinzu versorge man 30 menschen auf
einmal kein ende des leids die
ukrainische regierung befürchtet aus ihr
ziehen und anderswo habe sich der feind
zurückgezogen aber nur um sich neu zu
formieren und umso stärker anzugreifen
mittlerweile sind mehr als vier
millionen menschen vor dem krieg aus der
ukraine geflohen die meisten nach polen
mehr als 200 83.000 nach deutschland
viele sind gut ausgebildet und hier
fehlen fachkräfte bei einem
spitzentreffen in berlin ging es heute
um ganz praktische probleme wie
sprachbarrieren oder die anerkennung von
abschlüssen
manchmal geht es aber auch ganz schnell
zeigt elisabeth schmidt
vor wenigen wochen stand ludmilla
maestro noch vor ihrer klasse in odessa
und unterrichtete deutsch explosionen
krieg sie floh nach holzminden in
niedersachsen wo sie bereits als
austausch lehrerin gearbeitet hatte
jetzt unterrichtet sie hier ukrainische
jugendliche
für mich ist es und auch so glück im
unglück dass ich auch mit denen arbeite
dass ich auch mit ihren zusammen in
einer gruppe fühle und das ist ein
gegenseitiger hilfe für die schule an
absoluter glücksfall in niedersachsen
gibt es so wenige lehrkräfte wie zuletzt
vor 19 jahren auch in anderen branchen
fehlt fachpersonal experten gehen davon
aus dass etwa die hälfte der
ukrainischen flüchtlinge einen
hochschulabschluss hat der
arbeitsminister will sie jetzt schneller
in jobs bringen es würde den menschen
nicht gerecht die was können wenn man
sie sozusagen in prekäre arbeit oder am
rande einsetzen würde deshalb ist das
eine zentrale frage zu validieren welche
qualifikation bitkom und schneller zu
werden was auch die anerkennung von
qualifikationen betrifft doch nach
registrierung und arbeitserlaubnis gibt
es weitere hürden sprache erlernen
kinderbetreuung finden wir kommen
hierher
und müssen sich dann in dem arbeitsmarkt
orientieren das heißt wir rechnen damit
wenn es gut läuft dass nach einem jahr
vielleicht 15 20 prozent der menschen
die einer beschäftigung nachgehen unklar
ist wie viele menschen bleiben werden
ludmilla maestro sagt so gerne sie in
holzminden unterrichtet viel lieber
würde sie das wieder in der heimat tun
der krieg in der ukraine drückt auch die
aussichten der deutschen wirtschaft
deutlich im herbst hatte der
sachverständigenrat noch 4,6 prozent
wachstum für dieses jahr erwartet jetzt
sind es nur noch 1,8 auch eine
schrumpfende wirtschaft seien nicht mehr
auszuschliessen
schon jetzt machen sich die folgen des
krieges auch finanziell bemerkbar denn
die ohnehin schon hohe inflation steigt
weiter lag sie vor einem jahr noch bei
1,7 prozent so sind es nun
7,3 wir alle spüren es im supermarkt
aber mehr noch beim heizen und tanken
über 39 prozent der teuerung gehen auf
die höheren energiepreise zurück manche
firmen kommen da doppelt ans limit
mehrausgaben und gleichzeitig drängen
die gewerkschaften auf höhere löhne
stefan schlosser
bis zu 1300 liter fließen in die tanks
dieses lkws die tankrechnung tut
speditionsunternehmer christoph weller
kam jedes mal richtig wie also extrem
gestiegen ist der dieselpreis zeit der
ukraine seitdem ukraine krieg um 50 cent
brutto an der tankstelle das was jeder
im prinzip sieht das macht bei uns im
jahr pro lkw 18.000 euro aus bei 30
fahrzeugen und fernverkehr sondershausen
knapp 500.000 euro im jahr rund zehn
prozent vom umsatz die müssen erst
einmal verdient werden und auch die
fahrer fragen schon nach mehr lohn die
steigenden preise gerade für energie
treffen alle vergangene woche noch
streikten beschäftigte an den deutschen
flughäfen für mehr geld sie bekommen
jetzt ein plus von bis zu sieben prozent
auch bei den aktuellen
tarifverhandlungen in der chemiebranche
spielt die inflation eine wichtige rolle
wir haben den inflationsausgleich zur
forderungen gemacht natürlich wirkt die
inflation steigerung auf beiden seiten
und insbesondere was die energiepreise
angeht aber eben auch bei unseren
beschäftigten
besonnenheit ist jedoch gefragt es
folgen noch einige tarifrunden in diesem
jahr kräftige lohnzuwächse könnten die
preise weiter steigen lassen und eine
lohn-preis-spirale in gang bringen
wichtig ist dass die europäische
zentralbank jetzt zügig aus steigt aus
der lockeren geldpolitik damit alle
wissen in der mittleren sicht kommt die
inflation wieder runter und dann werden
auch die gewerkschaften keine
aggressiven forderungen stellen jetzt
noch deutlich höhere lohnkosten das
würde die situation von christoph
wettkampf spedition und von vielen
anderen unternehmen noch schwieriger
machen
ab montag sollen in deutschland die
meisten maßnahmen gegen korona entfallen
aber nicht überall nach mecklenburg
vorpommern hat sich jetzt auch hamburg
wegen hoher instanzen zum hot spot
erklärt und will so wesentliche regeln
wie etwa die masken pflicht beibehalten
der bald sinken die korona zahlen leicht
das robert koch institut meldet 268
1477 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
das sind 15 1255 weniger als in der
vorwoche an oder mit corona starben 348
menschen die sieben tage incidents sinkt
leicht auf
in der pandemie haben pflegekräfte und
krankenhauspersonal besonderes geleistet
dafür soll es noch in diesem jahr einen
bonus geben und zwar gestaffelt bis zu
2500 euro pro person sowie die
bundesregierung sicherstellen dass die
bis zu 1,5 millionen beschäftigten nicht
nur applaus bekommen frank buchwald
applaus am offenen fenster ein
dankeschön für pflegekräfte auf dem
höhepunkt der pandemie nun hat das
kabinett einen pflege bonus beschlossen
für alle die tag und nacht im einsatz
sind
daher möchte ich mich auch nochmal
persönlich dafür bedanken da ist die
pflegekräfte hier so viel gemacht haben
und immer noch so viel machen
vollzeitbeschäftigte können einmalig mit
etwa 550 euro rechnen je nach belastung
andere beschäftigte mit rund 370 euro
wenn sie mindestens 25% pflegedienst
geleistet haben fach und intensivpflege
sollen mehr bekommen auf der grundlage
der jetzigen berechnungen vorliegenden
werte für die fach pflegekräfte durften
bei ungefähr 1700 euro liegen und die
auto fast nie fachpflege kräfte in der
intensivversorgung dürften mindestens
2500 euro bonus bekommen für die
pflegekräfte bleibt der bonus steuer und
abgabenfrei nicht schlecht findet auch
die gewerkschaft verdi wünscht sich aber
deutlich mehr wir wollen dass der
gesetzgeber klar definiert wer wie viel
bonus bekommt und wir wünschen uns
natürlich für alle beschäftigten eine
spürbare wirksame anerkennung die dem
tatsächlich auch gerecht wird das hier
seit über zwei jahren harte belastung
über alle berufe den weg gebracht wurden
in den krankenhäusern und auf den
intensivstationen leisten sie weiterhin
ihren dienst zwischen tod und leben er
zerrt an kräften und an den nerven mit
geld allein kaum zu entlohnen und die
pandemie ist noch immer nicht vorbei
israel erlebt die blutigste woche seit
vielen jahren elf menschen sind bei
insgesamt drei anschlägen getötet worden
gestern abend hatte ein palästinenser
bei tel aviv mit einem sturmgewehr fünf
menschen auf offener straße erschossen
der attentäter wurde von der polizei
getötet im westjordanland nahm die armee
sechs männer fest offenbar verwandte des
attentäters die palästinensischen
al-aksa-brigaden
kündet und weitere anschläge an
und jetzt fußball norbert ein munteres
eins zu eins 2000 gäste zwischen
niederlanden und deutschland tolles
spiel mit reinen das weißen das spiel
die dfb elf zwar nicht in topbesetzung
dafür aber mit einer topleistung erster
halbzeit dominierte deutschland zweiter
halbzeit oranien ein gerechtes
unentschieden auch der bundestrainer
zufrieden er wirkte nach dem ersten
nicht gewonnen spiel lockerer als nach
allen acht siegen zuvor die erste große
prüfung unter flick zeigte ein
widerstandsfähiges team das durch müller
verdient in führung ging angesichts der
vielen ausfälle ein nachbarschaftsduell
das mut macht die mannschaft hat über
weite strecken des spiels
die niederlande weg ist er unter
kontrolle gehabt und von da ist immer
zufrieden aber die art und weise wie er
fußball gespielt und ich glaube das
lässt sich sehen mitte der zweiten
halbzeit kassierten sie noch den
ausgleich durch werk waren danach wurde
ein elfmeter zurückgenommen
fehlentscheidung denn kehrer foulte
detail und erst dann spielte er den ball
recht für oranje und van gaal dennoch
mit müller scherzte ein wiedersehen in
aller freundschaft
unschöne szenen dagegen beim
afrikanischen playoff finale der fußball
wm qualifikation zwischen senegal und
ägypten durch laserpointer von den
zuschauertribünen wurden neben liverpool
star sala auch andere ägyptische
schützen beim entscheidenden
elfmeterschießen geblendet sala
verschoss ebenso wie zwei andere
teamkollegen
senegal gewann am ende mit 3 zu 1 die
fifa kündigte eine untersuchung an und
ganz regulär haben gestern abend die
stürmerstars robert lewandowski und
cristiano ronaldo die wm-tickets mit
ihren nationalmannschaften gelöst polen
besiegte schweden und portugal nord
mazedonien jeweils mit 2 0
die auslosung der wm-gruppen dann am
freitag
bundestrainer toni söder holm bleibt dem
deutschen eishockey bund nun doch noch
länger erhalten nach dem enttäuschenden
abschneiden des olympia teams in peking
war über seinen abschied spekuliert
worden jetzt hat der international
umworbene finne seinen vertrag bis 1026
verlängert das wars vom sport dankeschön
norbert zum schluss noch ein stück
hoffnung auf verbundenheit
letzten acht auf der internationalen
raumstation iss fliegen sich russen und
amerikaner in den rahmen feiern ihre
gute zusammenarbeit verabschieden sich
und dann nehmen die russen ihren us
kollegen mit in die sojus kapsel und sie
kommen gemeinsam nach hause auf unserem
blauen planeten
zurück zum schnöden mammon die
gewinnzahlen vom mittwochslotto lauten 6
12 13 27 34 41 und die superzahl 3
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf
seite 5 157
es wird winterlich in den nächsten tagen
in der nacht geht es schon los mehr dazu
gleich beim wetter von osten her lee
marietta slomka spricht eben heute schon
einmal um viertel vor zehn mit
wirtschaftsminister habeck wir danken
für ihr interesse und wünschen ihnen
noch einen guten abend bis morgen
[Musik]
schön kunde und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter in der arktischen kaltluft die
uns vom polarkreis erreicht von norden
her richtung süden wandert hat sich ein
tief gebildet und diese steve hat es in
sich nämlich viel schnee zunächst einmal
im nordwesten deutschlands in der nacht
und hier wird es vor allem richtung
nordsee dann schneien und das setzt sich
allmählich südwärts voran noch ist sogar
auch regen dabei aber es kann sich hier
schon eine schneedecke bilden im süden
dagegen gibt es erstmal ring fälle
dazwischen ist es trocken die
temperaturen nach osten hin bei minus
zwei grad aber häufig schon im norden
temperaturen um die null grad marke
sieben grad plus gibt es im südwesten
dort ist es am mildesten morgen dann im
nordwesten weitere schneefälle und
dieser schnee setzt sich allmählich
weiter richtung mittelgebirge es kann
dann auch mal bis ins flachland herunter
schneien im süden gibt es regen und im
osten eher sonnenschein die temperaturen
maximalwerte richtung nordsee schauen
sie gerade mal zwei grad plus sonst ganz
im süden elf grad das wäre die
temperaturspanne am freitag gibt es
ergiebige schneefälle in der mitte
deutschlands dann kann sich auch im
flachland sogar eine schneedecke
ausbilden temperaturen maximal null bis
sieben grad und die nächsten tage lässt
der schnee ganz langsam nach ein schöner
abend